vous êtes sur france 24 et vous avez
raison bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'afrique à la une ce soir le coup
d'état militaire au burkina faso le
président a été renversé roch marc
christian kaboré aurait échappé à une
tentative d'assassinât est retenu dans
un lieu secret après une journée confuse
où beaucoup d'informations
contradictoires ont circulé
nous tenterons de faire le point sur la
situation cette édition sera largement
consacré au burkina faso nous irons à
ouagadougou rejoindre notre
correspondant kalidou sy et le
journaliste spécialiste la politique
africaine antoine glaser est avec nous
en plateau
après deux jours un dimanche de
mutineries et plusieurs heures
d'incertitude et 2 des informations
contradictoires c'est au tour du burkina
faso de faire face à un coup d'état
militaire des hommes armés ont annoncé
la démission du président de la
république
la suspension de la constitution la
dissolution du gouvernement de
l'assemblée nationale la fermeture des
frontières terrestres et aériennes et un
couvre feu de 21 heures à 5 heures du
matin sur toute l'étendue du territoire
national olivier fait sol nous fait le
point sur les derniers événements
peuple du burkina faso en apparaissant à
la télévision nationale les militaires
clarifie la situation
il s'agit bien d'un coup d'état après
les mutineries de dimanche dans
plusieurs casernes du pays l'armée a
donc décidé de prendre le pouvoir
le burkina serait maintenant dirigée par
les putschistes qui se sont nommés
mouvement patriotique pour la sauvegarde
et la restauration
le mps est à la connaissance de
l'opinion nationale et internationale
que
1 la constitution est suspendue
2 le gouvernement est dissous trois
l'assemblée nationale est dissoute
les frontières terrestres et aériennes
sont fermés à la tête des putschistes le
lieutenant colonel polhenri sandaogo
damiba au premier rang à gauche béret
rouge sur la tête engagé dans la lutte
contre le terrorisme
il aurait étudié la criminologie en
france le président kaboré lui serait
retenu en résidence surveillée à
ouagadougou
selon son entourage ce matin des
véhicules appartenant à la flotte
présidentielle et portant des impacts de
balles avaient été retrouvés à quelques
centaines de mètres de la résidence du
chef de l'état le sort du président
était alors inconnu et en milieu d'après
midi ce message a été posté sur son
compte twitter
notre nation vit des moments difficiles
nous devons ce moment précis sauvegarder
nos acquis démocratiques
j'invite ceux qui ont pris les armes
allaient déposer dans l'intérêt
supérieur de la nation c'est par le
dialogue et l'écouté que nous devons
régler nos contradictions ce coup de
force des militaires fait suite à un
week end de troubles aux manifestations
pour protester contre l'inaction du
pouvoir face aux nombreuses attaques
jihadistes se sont ajoutés des
mutineries de soldats ce dimanche des
soldats qui réclamaient plus de moyens
et le départ des chefs de l'armée
également accusée d'incompétence face à
la menace terroriste
le même jour le siège du parti
présidentiel dans la capitale a été
saccagé et nouveaux maîtres du pays ont
assuré qu'un calendrier de retour à
l'ordre constitutionnel serait proposée
dans un délai raisonnable le secrétaire
général des nations unies à lui
fermement condamné le coup d'état
on va à présent à ouagadougou rejoindre
notre correspondant kalidou sy bonsoir
kalidou quelle est la situation actuelle
dans la capitale et surtout comment
réagissent les burkinabè à l'annonce de
ce coup d'état
à écouter tout ce que je peux vous dire
c'est qu'après une journée remplie
d'incertitudes on peut dire que tu perds
soulagement chez beaucoup de burkinabè
soulagement d'avoir des réponses aux
deux principales questions des 20
dernières 24 heures au burkina faso il
ya eu un coup d'état et qu'il est le
nouvel homme fort du pays
oui alors la journée de dimanche vous
l'avais dit à celle d'aujourd'hui ont
été longues semaines d'incertitude et
d'informations contradictoires ce qui
jette d'ailleurs le trouble dans le pays
on imagine oui ce fut 24 dernières
heures créant paiement pour les
burkinabè au vu des événements qui se
sont déroulés dans le ring tout a
commencé hier par les coups de feu dans
différentes casernes pays on ne parlait
pas encore de coup d'état mais de
mutinerie ou de mouvements d'humeur
surtout que dans la journée le ministre
de la défense était présenté sur le
plateau d' appuyer nos nationale en
affirmant que le chef d'état avait été
enlevée mais en confirmant également
cette mutinerie et dans l'après midi de
dimanche tout est revenu dans le calme
depuis aux alentours de 23 heures des
coups de feu ont retenti près de la
résidence privée du président camou et
ce matin on a monté que père détenait le
président a moment là on nous répond en
prêt dans une journée d'incertitude
incertitudes tout d'abord le standard se
sont réunis autour de la télévision
nationale aux alentours de 8 heures avec
des blindés et on s'est dit qu'il n'a
nulle part donc une allocution ne
devrait pas tarder une heure après deux
heures après trois heures après toujours
pas de prise de parole et c'est à ce
moment là qu'une deuxième version des
faits de l'entourage du président nous
disaient qu'ils avaient réussi à
exfiltrer le président farid en privé
avant l'arrivée des militaires et qui se
trouve être en sécurité peu après le
compte twitter du président a posté un
message
le fou était le plus total mais à 17h25
heure locale le couperet tombe lorsqu'il
août à paray fait rater des niveau
national pour annoncer ne coulait pas
alors on dit que le président kaboré à
démissionner donc il aurait été démis de
ses fonctions selon l'expression des
putschistes on a parlé de tentative de
coup d'état est ce que on en sait plus
d'assassinats plutôt est ce qu'on en
sait plus sur son intégrité physique par
exemple
l'appareil on a deux versions qui
s'opposent celle du parti au pouvoir le
mpp qui dénoncé dans un communiqué une
tentative avortée d'assassinât du
président à croire qu'ils sont cabrés
ils dénonçaient également le saccage du
domicile privé du chef de l'état une
tentative d'assassinât d'un ministre la
république et la destruction de biens
publics et privés mais lors de leurs
allocutions à la télévision publique les
militaires eux ont précisé que ce coup
d'état préférant réfusant de sang et
sans violence donc lhi les prochaines
heures et femelles nous en diront plus
sur ce qu'il en est et vraiment et sur
la maturité physique du président
cabourg ont alors rapidement kalidou que
savons nous des mutins en particulier
celui qui dirige qui serait à la tête de
cette mutinerie polhenri sandaogo damiba
que pouvaient pas absolument nous savons
très peu de choses sur paulo ribeiro
damiba même s'ils ont fait des
commentaires sur tous les toits les
réseaux sociaux tout ce qu'on sait c'est
qu'un panneau pitié supérieur
d'infanterie dans la même optique ab qui
est diplômé de l'école militaire de
paris il a commandé la 3e région
militaire du burkina et d'après ce qu'on
dit c'est pas militaire courageux ce nom
d'autres militaires on a pu interroger
merci merci beaucoup kalidou sy pour ces
précisions en point de laser merci
d'être avec nous sur le plateau du
journal d'afrique de france 24 on l'a vu
des images familières de soldats souvent
capitaine qui se transforme en
présentateur télé et qui annonce mettre
fin aux fonctions d'un président élu que
vous inspirent ces images déjà on savait
quand même qu'au burkina faso depuis un
moment il y avait vraiment un problème
entre le président roch kaboré et
l'armée qui a fait quand même pas
oublier que le président henri kaboré a
tous avaient une certaine défiance
vis-à-vis de cette armée puisque c'était
quand même plus tôt l'armée de blaise
compaore et quand tu y arrives tu es
arrivé au pouvoir on a bien vu que il a
sans doute ce que reproche d'ailleurs
les mutins non pas qu'ils ont pas
vraiment équipés et on a vu je crois que
c'est même à france 24
voici menaces qui avaient qui avait
révélé que par exemple aux morts parce
que c'est un tournant c'est unia tard si
jouer dans cette province du soum qu'il
ya eu 57 gendarmes qui sont morts
cinquante sept personnes tous nos
quarante neuf gendarmes qu en été qui
sont morts et il n'avait pas ce n'était
pas simplement un problème d'équipement
c'était un problème aussi pour
s'alimenter et qu'ils allaient chasser
un peu les des animaux autour de leur
campement pour pouvoir manger donc c'est
vrai que c'est on voit bien qu un vrai
problème entre roch kaboré et son armée
parce qu'ils avaient peur d'une
tentative de coup d'état et moi j'ai été
surpris par l'ampleur avait fait pour un
livre sur le piège african macron de
voir le président français en septembre
2020 quand on l'avait interviewé eric
pascal airault et nous avait dit roch
kaboré il a peur de son armée il veut
pas réformer son arme et donc il y avait
vraiment un problème comme ça et c'est
le contraire du mali au mali c'était
d'abord un soulèvement populaire et
ensuite vous avez eu un coup d'état ça
veut dire qu'un accompagnement de des
militaires là c'est quand même le
contraire c'est vraiment l'armée qui en
a marre qu était sous-équipé et on voit
bien quand même que les djihadistes
descente de plus en plus et comme comme
rgab aurait fait pas confiance à son
armée c'est vrai qu'il a tendance à
s'appuyer sur les volontaires pour la
défense et sécurité des civils sont des
civils les civils sauf que là vous
risquez d'avoir des problèmes
intercommunautaires comme on a vu un
certain nombre de cas dans le pays
donc je dire bien sûr mais je vais pas
dire oui donnez un coup d'état remet
enfin il ya quelques jours apparemment
le président kaboré avait arrêté déjà un
certain nombre un lieutenant et d'autres
qui étaient des proches finalement de la
même qu'on en rit sandaogo
damiba donc je veux dire c'est pas c'est
pas une surprise c'est assez le pays à
l'aller de plus en plus mal à partir du
moment mais encore une fois moi je fais
pas il faut pas penser que c'est pareil
que le mali c'est pareil que la guinée
c'est bien sûr ce sont des putschistes
bien sûr ce sont des coups d'état dans
toute cette zone sahélo saharienne les
finalement on a l'impression qu'il ya
une semoule guérissent dans les
capitales il abandonne tout l'espace
rural aux djihadistes oies à des gens
qui n'ont pu tuer l'oubli ce sont des
états qui ont abondé tous leurs pouvoirs
régaliens de d'éducation de santé puis
je dire au burkina faso il ya eu quand
même deux mille morts il ya eu 5 million
de personnes sont déplacées
mais je viens au bout d'un moment j'ai
on sent bien que c'est pas possible de
continuer dans la même situation ça ne
veut pas dire j'ai encouragé coup d'état
oui alors bien sûr on entend bien mais à
l'envers je vous propose de revenir sur
les attaques qui se sont multipliées
vous l'avez dit depuis sept ans on a vu
le cadre hinata mais y en a eu d'autres
hélas contre les forces armées et les
civils avec inès olhagaray on en parle
juste après
depuis sept ans la menace djihadiste se
fait de plus en plus forte au burkina
faso des groupes affiliés à al qaïda
l'état islamique font régner la terreur
principalement dans le nord et l'est du
pays dans la zone dite des trois
frontières près du mali et du niger
entre 2016 et 2018 les djihadistes
frappe surtout ouagadougou la capitale
le 15 janvier 2016 un double attentat
visant un restaurant et un hôtel faisant
30 morts et des dizaines de blessés deux
ans plus tard mais l'ambassade de france
et l'état major des forces armées du
burkina façon sont attaqués les
djihadistes sévissent désormais surtout
dans des zones rurales mais les
burkinabè subissent aussi de nombreuses
violences intercommunautaires comme en
janvier 2019 dans la province du
sanmatenga lorsque des affrontements
entre peu les mots siphon 72 morts et
6000 déplacer la tacc du village de soul
and est sans doute la plus meurtrière le
5 juin 2021 160 civils ont été exécutés
en pleine nuit
l'attaqué est attribuée à une unité
indisciplinés du gym mais cette filière
d'al qaïda très actif dans la région nie
toute responsabilité
les islamistes ont aussi infligé de
lourdes pertes aux forces de sécurité en
novembre dernier l'assaut contre la
gendarmerie digne at a fait 57 morts les
gendarmes affaibli à cause du manque de
vivres des munitions ont été encerclés
par plusieurs centaines de combattants
lourdement armés
depuis 2004 les violences ou burkina
faso ont fait au total plus de 2000
victimes et un million et demi de
déplacés
antoine glaser louis reparler l'eau
justement de toutes ces violences et des
attaques via liste mais on se demande
est ce que le burkina seule l'armée
burkinabè est en mesure de faire face à
ces attaques qui a dit justement oui ça
veut dire parce que le décès c'est pas
simplement une question sécuritaire
c'est évident que si l'état burkinabé
avait requis nabé avait exercé son
pouvoir régalien en matière de non
seulement disputé mes économies en
matière de santé en matière d'éducation
en matière d'école est haute je veux
dire s'ils vont abandonner le terrain
quelque part donc c'est ça le problème
de fond c'est un problème que l'armée
est totalement hors sol s'il n'y a pas
un accompagnement niveau santé éducation
et s'il n'y a pas un soutien économique
à ce moment là qui décide dans les
villages des problèmes de justice et
autres ce sont des djihadistes i non
seulement ça mais en plus ils font même
il s'occupe du foncier ce qui
répartissent même les territoires dans
les villages c'est l'absence d'état
avant tout en dehors même du militaire
en dehors même du militaire aux
revenants quand même sur la question
militaire à la question de la france
parce qu'il ya un sentiment anti
français on sait qui grandit pas
uniquement au mali mais aussi au burkina
faso on a une impression à un moment
donné que paris avait quelque peu lâché
le président kaboré est ce que justement
est ce que c'est ça qui a finalement
précipité sa chute si on peut dire je
pense pas que paris a laissé tomber le
président rogge à bord et même si c'est
vrai qu'il y avait ces même si quand
même les forces spéciales françaises qui
avaient exceed exfiltré en côte d'ivoire
le président blaise compaore et c'est
vrai qu'il ya eu toujours un soutien à
quelqu'un comme gilbert dienderé il ya
toujours un souci à la dgse française
c'est vrai que les services français ont
tellement pendant très longtemps
bénéficié de la plate forme de
ouagadougou pour toutes ses opérations
en particulier clandestines dans la
région sylvain qu'elle vient un soutien
français à blaise compaore ça veut pas
dire que la france n'est pas heureux
kaboré mais c'est vrai il sert kaboré
lui même qui était très cave une
certaine distance même vis-à-vis de la
france jeudi dans une prison français
qu'il voulait pas réformé son armée etc
il veut refuser en dehors de l'opération
sabres des forces spéciales françaises
qui sont actuellement près de
ouagadougou sur une base etc en dehors
de cette opération de forces spéciales
très particulière c'est vrai que roch
kaboré ne tenait pas avoir une opération
barkan dans son pays parce que barkan
c'est quand même une sorte de forces
conventionnelles à l'ancienne et qui est
un peu bas maintenant on voit bien un
peu hors sol et qu'un somme de problèmes
et qui attire finalement un certain
nombre toute la jeunesse africaine
considère qu'on est encore dans les
années de la françafrique et autres et
donc il c'est vrai que rga borie a été
abaissée à certains nombres de distance
très aussi parce que lui c'était quand
même ce puits a toujours été gouverné
par des militaires les burkina faso
c'était quand même le premier vrai
président civil sauf que c'était quand
même accompagnons route de blaise
compaore pendant des années il faut pas
l'oublier qui était premier ministre
blaise compaore donc qu'ils
connaissaient quand même le système de
l'intérieur
mais c'est vrai que vis-à-vis de la
france il avait une certaine retenue oui
absolument merci merci beaucoup antoine
cazères pour tous et éclairage et nous
reparlerons évidemment de la situation
au burkina dans les prochaines éditions
et sur france 24
évidemment on passe à la guinée on
connaît désormais la composition du
conseil national la transition dans un
décret lu à la télévision d'état le
président de la transition le colonel
mamadou doumbouya a dévoilé la liste des
81 membres de cet organe qui doit
légiférer pendant toute la durée de la
transition en cours depuis le coup
d'état du 5 septembre contre le régime
d'alpha condé les guinéens attendent
impatiemment la mise en place de cet
organe des explications avec notre
correspondant à conakry mali diakité c4e
21 membres regroupe des représentants
des partis politiques de la société
civile des syndicats et des militaires
le conseil national de la transition est
doté des prérogatives de l'assemblée
nationale dissoute le 5 septembre
dernier c'est lui qui doit élaborer une
nouvelle constitution qui sera soumise à
un référendum et fixer le calendrier du
retour des civils au pouvoir dans les
rues de conakry les guinéens attendent
beaucoup de cet organe moi en tant que
citoyen je souhaitais que le cnt
travaille surtout pour nous proposer une
constitution qui pourra nous aider à
organiser les élections libres et
inclusive et transparente yeux et on a
beaucoup attendu le père ne peut pas
fait développer faire un président
légitimement élu
d'un combat faire rapidement les choses
dix-huit mois vers moi pourrait arranger
les choses
selon plusieurs sources le conseil
national de la transition sera installé
dans les jours à venir la détermination
de la durée de la transition qui n'est
toujours pas connue fait partie de ses
priorités
c'est une information très attendu par
la cédéao communauté économique des
états de l'afrique de l'ouest
au sénégal toujours pas de résultats
définitifs pour les élections locales
qui se sont tenues hier mais de grandes
tendances se sont dégagées l'opposition
a pris le dessus sur les deux mairies
les plus convoitées avec barthélémy dias
à dakar et ousman sonko à ziguinchor la
plus grande ville du sud du pays
deux sont membres de la coalition
d'opposition y est oui ascani et il hier
soir leurs partisans ont paradé dans les
vues de son côté la majorité
présidentielle qui assure avoir concédé
sa défaite dans les deux grandes villes
crient victoire dans la majorité des
circonscriptions électorales du pays
et on vous rappelle l'information
principale de cette édition le coup
d'état militaire au burkina faso le
président de la république royce avéré a
été démis de ses fonctions les
frontières fermées un couvre-feu
instauré jusqu'à 5 heures du matin c'est
ainsi que renferme ce journal l'afrique
merci à tous ceux qui nous ont suivis et
en particulier tous au burkina faso
[Musique]